now i think in case this gets awkward
later i think i should bring this up
now yes that uh john bishop you do have
a connection to tom cruise uh yes yes
you do
yes uh yeah we do have a connection
because we were both
i was on uh top gear shortly after
tom was on top gear this is the star in
a reasonably nice car
the star in the reasonably priced car
and you did very well top
i did all right yeah yeah you top of the
leaderboard how did you do john
yeah here's the leaderboard
john bishop yeah beat you two seconds
well done through gritted teeth
because what happened was me there was
tom cruise he was covering the ass
and then and then ripper clinch his
fourth wasn't he rupert grint
yes
tell me that you didn't just beat us you
crushed us
that's 142.8 that's that's a good uh
full second and a half almost i know and
the thing is like you can drive cars and
you're
interested i've got zero interest in
cars
you chose the wrong profession tell me
about it i came away from that thing and
i should be an f1 because all it was to
me though was somebody give me a car
yeah and said it doesn't matter if you
crash it
this is great this is like being 17
again on my dad's insurance
[Applause]
[Laughter]
were you already a prankster at 11 were
you one of those kids
yeah i thought things were funny i mean
i think uh yes
i i thought there were things that were
funny to do got in trouble in school a
lot so i guess
and i hear even your kids now well
they're three they're already being
pranksters
yeah i've been so look my kids are
clearly
my wife's children right they are three
and they speak
fluent italian and they they're you know
way ahead
my wife's a genius they're brilliant
kids it is my job
to dumb them down it's my job to put
you know the actor in them a little bit
and so i i teach them
horrible things that because remember
it's only the four of us
so i just want to hear the shriek from
my wife and i know i've succeeded
so i taught him to put nutella in their
nappy
and then go upstairs and take it off and
then pick it up and eat it
and the sound you hear it might be you
ever
who has a 15 month old some one of you
guys michael yeah both of us well both
of you do okay i know
very elegant teach them this move i
promise you it's going to be good
just do it i'm sure you know we've had
lots of stars of your movies
on the show and then i wasn't sure
whether you knew this or not but
apparently you do
that matthew perry was on the show and
told this extraordinary
anecdote involving uh him
thinking he'd spent a night with you
but apparently there is you do know
about it and there is an
m night shyamalan twist to this anecdote
well yeah this is so he went on your
show and he tells the story of being out
with me all night
and then at the end of the night he's
having the greatest time and at the end
of the night he meets one of his friends
and and
his friends like how's it going and he
says it's the greatest night of my life
i've been hanging out with m night
shyamalan and then the guy turns and
says
that's not him night shyamalan and he's
been hanging out with a random
indian dude all night long but but that
so then i'm watching it
and here's the twist we did actually
hang out
that's that's what's that's actually
what's so astonishing
okay so i've i've pieced it together and
i have a
a amateur sleuth uh answer for what
happened so
we were hanging out we we were hanging
out and we were we were having fun
and and then we matthew's like let's go
to another place
and i'm like i'm you know what i'm a
little tired i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna leave
here and you can go to the other place
meanwhile there's this kind of
fan that's been hanging about and he's
also indian and he's been a big fan he's
come over a couple times
wants to hang out with us and we're like
hey hey it's okay brother
and and he's over there and what i think
happened
is that matthew went on to continue
partying
and this other indian dude joined joined
him
and then later in that evening his
friend came over and said that's not m
night shyamalan and then matthew
thought he he second-guessed himself
that we actually had this evening
together
all these years later i have to see him
because i'm we did hang out we had a
great time and he was very funny
now weirdly we have sort of met we have
kind of met
yeah not on the show this is my first
time on i'm a little nervous so forgive
me if i ramble
but we i was doing um a broadway show
called hedwig and the angry inch
and you i had heard that you were going
to be in the audience
and it was this really nasty kind of
rock and roll uh
punk rock musical and you had sat in the
very
very front row if i'm not in the middle
in the middle of i didn't book these
tickets
now and you were with two other guys and
during the show there's a part where
where hedwig who's pretty randy and
nasty um
uh you know there's a good picture of
her she uh
she crawls in on down to the stage and
just picks someone in the audience and
makes out with them
so um i started down i i scanned the
crowd
i saw you i went right for you and i you
know i grabbed my tongue down your
throat
i have the taste of cheap lipstick in my
mouth for the rest of the show
so nice to meet you on this second day
nice to talk to you finally
now you've worked with uh mr tucci
haven't you kate
yes hello okay yes see
gary goes gagging on his boobs i know i
know i'm very happy to see you
very very happy to see you too so
presumably you've experienced
uh stan lee's cooking no i haven't
experienced
stanley's cooking um which is a tragedy
because clearly you're a marvelous chef
but
sally do you remember how much you
complained
when we worked together he would come
into work and he would say after
breakfast half an hour later he'd say
i mean i'm starving i mean there's
there's nothing to eat
i mean what do you do there's there's no
food i mean this is awful this is
this is just awful and then the next day
he came into work carrying this very
sort of neat and tidy little cooler bag
actually it's quite a large cooler bag
to be fair
and it was full of these perfectly
prepared
little tupperwares full of incredible
delights and everyone's like oh
leaning in oh stanley he's like no
you know you have to eat well don't you
when you're working
you have to yeah i don't want to throw
in there at this point but i was in fact
pregnant when yeah
and i didn't know that but you told me
that on the set
she told me she said i i can't remember
what we were talking about but you said
i'm pregnant and and she did that scream
whisper
you know yeah and i said oh yes i did
wonder
you yes you look really fat awful you
look really fat your boobs are huge but
you're still not having any of my
snacks yeah yeah even though you're
eating for two yeah you're reading for
two
this tupperware is sealed you were out
and about you did the traditional
uh pouring the pint of guinness well we
were shooting at this uh pub
and and they asked me to pour a pint of
guinness and i thought
this is gonna be amazing and i'm gonna
crush it didn't
at all so there was a crowd of people
who were actually in the pub
i think our movie was very tiny so there
was no sort of locking down of sets you
were just there you know people were
there
free-for-all and so there was a crowd of
people watching before the point who
were very uproaris at first they were
just like
cheering and then as the pint just
turned into a pint of foam
it just uh it just kind of dwindled to
nothing i think we've got a picture of
the paint
[Laughter]
that is sacrilege and also there's a
great i've got a big up there's an
instagram account called london
guinness
[Laughter]
i don't know some some legend i think
he's from cork or something and he
basically people put send them in these
awful like
notoriously terrible guinness here in
london and um
you know it's like no head at all loads
of head like sometimes a guinness
uh trying to get us in a like a heineken
glass like
dreadful but that would be straight on
there yeah
it could be a celebrity special i wasn't
there to oversee that that's
terrible it was really bad even
christopher walken was like that's bad
but how did you get that so wrong well i
thought i was doing all right and
there's i think it's the angle
i think it's the angle maybe too much
gas in the pipe too much gas in the pipe
just like jamie dornan
but now do you you have a trick to get
into it do you yeah absolutely so
when i was preparing i didn't know a
dairy accent first off and then i
thought who do i know and then i thought
oh nadine from girls aloud is extremely
dairy and then
i don't know if people will know this
but there was an extremely controversial
incident
in the early 90s in ireland so good it
was so good
it was the first irish sort of pop
culture tv moment it was
pop stars the irish version which only
had about 50 entrants because we don't
have a
bigger population um so she went on and
lied about her age
but she got found out on camera stop it
okay so she's gotten into the band and
then her on camera interview like the
first one to introduce yourself who you
are she said
my name is the dean coyla from lark hill
and there he did a birth 15th
685 mecca me and germany and then she
thinks for a second and goes
what did her birthday say you know 15th
of a sec and then it fades
and she's she's outed herself on camera
but everyone
lost the plot do the phone call to her
mother
mommy do the whole thing daddy put my
passport in the car
mommy will you look at my handbag for my
passport and it was all a lie she knew
she was 16 she was meant to be 18. what
is it about you lot pretending you're
different ages
cool isn't it cute because she wanted to
make it through that's but then but then
she got in girls allowed it actually
worked out much better
you see yeah yeah and we ended up with
an amazing moment of her sobbing in the
back of a renault spas being driven away
sarah pasco's had a very exciting
lockdown excited
have i yeah have i well haven't you oh
yeah well
i got married just beforehand so i've
had a very exciting time
yeah so it should have been kind of like
the new you know
married bliss and everything and then
there was a lockdown and we were stuck
together and they're flat all of the
time
and and it's not a very um it's not very
good for romance
so i decided i would do something to
kind of um keep the romance going and
what i did was very cliche i bought some
sexy pants
on a website and i brought them to show
you
this is not unhygienic by the way and
because they've never been worn
because they're too complicated
and if you can see that um you see how
there's too many leg holes
is the the pants that i brought they
were very expensive
um and also i showed one of my friends
that showed lou and she was like oh
they're crotchless they're not i promise
that's the crotch there did you have a
crutch
vouch for me nashville um so there we go
and um
and so they first arrived i i didn't
know it was going to be so difficult so
i just sent my husband out like oh
come in the bedroom in five minutes
you'll get a nice surprise and i just
i'll just put my pants on cause i've
never had trouble before you know
just assume it's gonna be easy i wasn't
wearing shoes i should say it wasn't as
complicated
and then i realized oh no there's always
other leg spaces
and i thought oh maybe it's for arms
[Laughter]
so those kind of arm pants maybe that's
why they're so
sexy and um and first of all
i was just you know very confused about
it and then um
then i got annoyed and then um i felt
lonely
and eventually i got you know very
frustrated and angry and i started
crying
and um and my husband was at the door
kind of like let me in what's wrong i
can't get these pants on
and then he was like he's australian
like oh i'll show
you because i think he thought i was
being really stupid
and like he would just show me how to
put on underwear and
then he came in and then he was
flummoxed as well and then he asked like
what website did you get him from and so
i told him and then
he found the page and he like shoved his
phone in my face
and um and i was looking at this woman
and she was much much younger than me
much thinner
um with very big boobs and she was all
shiny with oil
and she must have been like a mensa
member because she was wearing these
and he was like that's what they're
supposed to look like
the sex was cancelled
i said earlier you've been married for
40 years but but oddly i think i'm
writing saying
uh you never proposed samuel
do that mixed up things
i want to hear this story you never
proposed
i don't remember well i don't remember
it actually i
i i do remember you
having some invitations in your hand and
saying this is when this is happening no
that's not what happened no
i said my grandfather is very ill
and he's going to die and he's very
concerned that we are not
married so we have to get married now
uh so that he can walk me down the aisle
that was his concern that
i was the last of his grandchildren um
not to be walked down the aisle in
marriage so so we have to get married so
now you have to ask him if you may marry
me
and then you have to ask me will i marry
you and you did
i did yes you did
okay okay it doesn't matter
but the wedding itself it was all
romantic i got down on one knee and did
the whole thing
no it was semantical but you know we did
i didn't say semantical i said romantic
later on today
you